so
if somebody shows that p equals np
what do you think that proof will look
like
if you were to put on yourself if it's
possible to show that
as a proof or to demonstrate an
algorithm
all i can say is that it will involve
concepts that we do not now have
and approaches that we don't have do you
think those concepts are out there
in terms of inside complexity theory
inside of computational analysis of
algorithms do you think there's concepts
that are totally outside of the box
that we haven't considered yet i think
that if there is a proof that p is equal
to np or that p is not equal to np
uh it'll depend on concepts that are now
outside the box now if that's shown
either way p
equals np or p not well actually p
equals np
what impact you kind of mentioned a
little bit but can you
can you linger on it what kind of impact
would it have
on theoretical computer science and
perhaps software
these systems in general well i think it
would have enormous impact on the
on the world any in either way case
if p is unequal to np which is what we
expect
then we know that we're in that for the
great majority of the combinatorial
problems that come up
since they're known to be np complete
we're not going to be able to solve them
by efficient algorithms
however there's a little bit of
hope in that it may be that we can solve
most instances
all we know is that if a problem is not
in p that
then it can't be solved efficiently on
all instances
but but basically it will
it will if we find that p is unequal to
np it will mean that we can't
expect always to get the optimal
solutions to these problems
and we have to depend on heuristics that
perhaps work
most of the time or give us good
approximate solutions
but not so we would turn our eye towards
the heuristics
with a little bit more um acceptance and
comfort on our hearts
exactly
you